and they will be facing alexander wells
alexander wells 24 years old left-handed
pitcher
born in newcastle south wales australia
how about that
connor falefa pops this up at the mound
wells backing up now martin calls him
off and makes the play
control and command of the strike zone
has been his thing in the minor leagues
he's put up some big numbers by command
the minor leagues in his career 83 walks
jeff in just
530 innings pitched
some early contact here severino will
take care of this one so two pop-outs
dolis garcia
smokes this one into left field that's a
base hit and so the rangers have a
runner in the first inning here's low
lefty lefty
curveball that ball hit well deep out to
right field and it is gone
nathaniel lowe with a two run homer
and the rangers jump out tonight two
nothing well nathaniel taking advantage
of a mistake by weld spencer howard 18th
game of the season
ground ball right side of the infield
solac right there and he throws out
mullins
one gun here in the first
oh one
that one swung on flared off the end of
the bat into right center fiota base
head so about castle with his third hit
in five at bats in the series a one-out
single
one-one pitch
and this one popped up first base side
foul ground low
might have whom he does
[Applause]
and he bounces this one slowly to
shortstop kinder philippa makes the
throw in time
the inning is done
on one against valencia
shoots this one into shallow right field
severino is going to head to third base
and he will make it there
and so a soft single this time by
valencia but he'll set up runners at the
quarters for the orioles with one out
hit on the ground to second solak here's
one
martin
safe at first
severino is down to score and the
orioles have their first run
collins has added tons of value to this
orioles lineup got the tying run at
second base now he's going for a
30-30 season
mullins hits this one high and deep
center field at the track this one is
gone
there is history
cedric mullins stands alone the first
oriole ever with a 30-30 season cedric
mullins
leaves his stamp on the orioles
franchise
we have seen history
cedric mullins crowd pretty excited
first ever 30-30 season in orioles
history he gets it to center field tips
his cap they were asking for a curtain
call and that's what everybody's been
waiting for when is cedric mullins going
to get to 30-30 and
everyone appreciated that tonight they
have seen some history made at camden
yards it'll put a smile on your face for
sure
pitch and that ball pretty well struck
center field tavares going back deep
part of the yard he leaps and he got it
brings back a home run
what a play by leote tavares out in left
center field he timed his jump perfectly
and saved a home run so the rangers have
runners in first and third with one out
now
for dj peters the 3-2 swinging a drive
in the center field mullins coming on
and it falls for the base hit low comes
in to score it's an rbi single for dj
peters and the rangers get back to
within a run here at four to three
this ball in the air out to left field
hanging up a little bit peters to the
wall and he makes the catch second home
run stolen
by the rangers in the outfield tonight
and here's kevin brown and here's leonie
tavares a long drive caught at third by
kelvin gutierrez
now he tells the rangers if you want to
rob us of two home runs at the least i
can rob you of a base hit texas has not
hit the ball hard so far and yet they
have a runner third in a runner at first
t.j peters now the batter
out to third gutierrez
now castle holds the bag and the orioles
are able to strand two more men on base
for texas well done by fernando abode
orioles maintain their 4-3 lead
out to third base gutierrez has been a
busy man tonight
on the money yeah the rangers better
find somewhere else to hit it because
gutierrez is pretty good over there on
the corner
so crable is out orioles with the one
run lead and there is cole sulcer he is
coming in to try and protect it
2-1 from sulsa on the first base side of
the mound his pitch is golfed into short
right center mullen sprinting over
slowing down makes the catch
[Music]
on the ground that's a base hit into
left field
solac
chugs for second he'll be in there
easily
two out double
the rangers now
have that tying running scoring position
this is cued
salsa bare hands it throw to first in
time so they get holt
and the rangers despite the two out
double not able to score
[Applause]
there's a swing and there's a line shot
to left center peters on the run he
slides and he's got it nice play by
peters on a wicked top spin liner to the
gap in left center
he had to race to his left into the gap
and then went into a slide to catch that
ball and alan mckenna is going to come
up and
see what he can do mckenna hits a line
drive up the middle for a base hit
mel castle coming around and there's an
insurance run ryan mckenna an rbi single
and it's
5-3-0 this one in the air
center field mullins getting in position
underneath it peters tags he heads to
the plate he'll score sacrifice fly for
willie calhoun
and it's a one-run game uh
adolescent magic early in the year and
here he is
this ball ripped down the left field
line that's a fair ball and into the
corner
the game is tied the rangers take the
lead
two runs score
on the double by garcia and it's 6-5 in
the ninth inning
with the one-two
and that one up the middle that could be
two
one out there the throat of first not in
time rangers out of run abanez comes in
from third
going from first the throw to second is
cut off to throw back to the plate in
time rangers tried the double steal the
rangers are taking a quick look
upstairs take a look
oh yeah very safe
it's going to be a five run ninth inning
here we go
he was safe
this one hit sharply on the ground
sliding stops solac pops up and he gets
that throw to first in time great play
by solak on the backhand side sliding
out towards center field to his right
pitch
in the air and that should do it
tavares
closing in on garcia it's garcia who
takes care of it and this one is over
the rangers win it eight to five
[Applause]